Luca, welcome back!
Thanks. It's good to be back here.
So, how does it feel to be back?
It feels a bit like when I go back to Italy.
And everything is good, and people are great...
The espresso's better.
The espresso's good, yes. But things are a
bit complicated.
Of course
Yes, we do complexity here.
Right.
We have known each other for the longest time,
right?
You were an undergraduate when I first met you in Italy.
Yes.
I spent a sabbatical in Rome and there you
were. I was really amazed to meet you.
I have a good eye.
Yes, I was a senior in college. And you knew
my advisor, who I guess was your postdoc
at San Diego the year before.
I had a really
great time doing a somewhat research-oriented senior thesis.
And I didn't get any offer
of a real job after I graduated.
So I started doing grad school.
Great.
That seems to have worked out pretty well.
At some point, you started working at IBM.
Yes. Pilu Crescenzi, my advisor, he also knew
Madhu Sudan, who was at IBM at that point.
And in my second year of grad school, as was
pretty common for students in my program,
I was looking for somewhere to go to and spend
a period abroad. So I wrote to Madhu to say that
I would like to come to IBM and visit,
and the Italian government would pay for the visit.
And Madhu was happy. This was off-season,
so not in summer but in the fall, where they
don't have a lot of students in general. And
they were always happy to have someone new.
And so I went. And very luckily, just a few
weeks before going
I was reading this paper on PCP and hardness of approximation
that Mihir Bellare and Oded Goldreich and Madhu
had just put online. It was a 120-page paper.
And it was the first time that a lot of those
new ideas on how to go beyond the original
PCP construction and get stronger results
were written down with all the details. And
I'd been thinking about one section where
they show how you do reductions from PCP to
optimization problems with gadgets.
They had a very abstract way of thinking about that.
And I was thinking that it should be possible
to search for an optimal gadget automatically.
Right. So this is where this idea came from.
Okay, right. It originated in Italy. (Laughs.)
Indeed. So I flew to New York with Alitalia.
And they lost my bags, with all my stuff.
And I then had to get a car to get to the
IBM lab, which was a bit outside of New York City.
But I was not 25, so I couldn't rent
a car. And so my first day there, with no
clothes and no house and no car, but, still,
I had this idea.
And I told Madhu, and he immediately got it.
And then the following  day
he basically reexplained the idea to me, but much, much better.
Wow.
Then we talked to Greg Sorkin and David Williamson
who showed how it could be extended to other problems.
So in a few days, we had a pretty
nice piece of work.
Great. You kept working with Madhu after that
- or not?
We stayed in touch. Just before I left, we
were starting to work on a classification
of constraint-satisfaction problems.
I see.
Yes, of course.
Then I ran out of my graduate fellowship.
Which, the way it was working in Italy at
that point (or not working) was that the fellowship
would run out one year before you would actually
graduate. Or sort of the time it took to get
together the graduation bureaucracy took a
year after that. So I spent that gap-year
in Geneva. And I started to work on pseudorandomness
and extractors.
Yes, that was also very lucky.
So finally, I got officially my PhD and I
was going to spend a year again in New York
at IBM working with Madhu. But at that point,
Madhu got offered to move to MIT and so he
told me, would you like to come to MIT instead?
And I said, well, I would very much like to
come to MIT instead. And so off I went.
Then you went to Columbia after that year.
Yes - I was originally thinking that maybe
after that year abroad, I would go back to
Italy. But that year at MIT was life-changing:
There were a lot of great people there. Oded
Goldreich was there on sabbatical, and he
had a big impact on me. The students there,
they were... Amit Sahai was there, Salil Vadan,
Danny Lewin, Adam Klivans, Yevgeny Dodis,
Tal Malkin, Daniele Micciancio, Anna Lysyanskaya...
It was a great group. And in the spring semester,
we did this reading group to try to understand
the work of Avi Wigderson and Russell Impagliazzo
that had just come out, where they were showing
that P equals PPP under plausible assumptions.
And we actually spent like three months on
that, because that paper was building upon
five or six papers from the previous ten years.
We decided that we would really like to understand
the whole sequence - with no particular goal
in mind, because it seemed that the work of
Russell and Avi was the final word on the
matter. And, instead, that reading group led
to a lot of new work. So Adam Klivans had
this idea of applying the same stuff non-deterministically.
So, independently with Dieter van Melkebeek,
he proved that graph non-isomorphism is in
NP, under complexity assumptions. And then
I did this work on extractors and pseudorandom
generators that seems to be the best thing I've done.
Yes, well, we will be the judge, okay. (Laughs.)
Salil had some improvement on that that Omer
Reingold and Ran Raz also had independently.
So they started working together.
So Omer
and Salil started working together because of that.
Ran was also in that group?
No, Omer and Ran were in Israel. I told
Avi about the result, and Avi told Ran, and
then Ran asked for the paper, and then immediately
saw this improvement, and Salil also. And
that was the beginning of Omer and Salil working
together.
This had so much impact that even we at Berkeley
heard about it, and decided to hire you.
Yes. And at that point I had pretty much never
been to California. And I was enjoying life
in New York quite a bit. But everybody was
telling me that they wouldn't speak to me
again if I didn't accept the Berkeley offer.
Really? I thought it was only us who told
you that.
Sure. (Laughs.) But everybody else was very
adamant that I had to take this job.
Amazing. That's good to know. Great, so, that's how we became colleagues.
What I remember most fondly, is your
let's call it intellectual leadership
That whenever there was something interesting
you took the chalk, or took the
marker
and started explaining to us at Theory Lunch.
I learned so many things from you.
It was here that you started your blog - am I right?
Yes. This was in 2006. It was the first year
that Andy Yao had started his institute at
Tsinghua University in Beijing and one of
my students, Hoeteck Wee was spending a whole
year there. He was one of three American students
who were there - two from Berkeley, one from
MIT. So it was spring break of 2006; it was
in the middle of this year. And I went to
spend a week, giving a couple of talks to
the students there in Beijing - talking to
them and also seeing China for the first time.
So this before at least I had Facebook.
It was not before Facebook, but before your
Facebook.
Before I did, right. I'm a late adopter. So
I wanted someplace where I could send friends
pictures and stories of what was going on.
So much to say, yes, right.
So I started this blog, and I sent the link
to a couple of people. By the end of the week,
lots of people were reading it. So when I
came back, I thought, maybe I'll keep it running
for a few more weeks and write about some
technical stuff. And then eight years later,
it's still going.
I was a great fan; I hope to keep reading
it here
Additive combinatorics?
Yeah, that was a time that it seemed that
there was this work of Ben Green and Terry Tao
where they proved that the primes have
arbitrarily long arithmetic progressions.
And there was a notion of pseudorandomness
in that paper. They already knew that
dense sets of integers have arbitrary long arithmetic
progressions. And they knew that
the integers that in some technical sense are almost prime, are pseudorandom in a very strong sense. And
that the primes were dense inside these almost-primes.
And so they had this intuition that
if dense sets of integers have this property, sets that are dense in a pseudorandom sense will
also have this property. So they made it work.
And what I thought would be really interesting
was to see if there was a way to understand
what they were doing in the way we think about
pseudorandomness. Which there was, and that
led to a few interesting pieces of work.
And what came next?
You worked more on approximability
and PCP?
You worked on the Unique Games?
Yes. In complexity theory, the two areas I
keep going back to are hardness of approximation
and approximation algorithms, and pseudorandomness
and average-case complexity. And it was at
that point that it seemed that these areas
and additive combinatorics had some connection
that I wanted to explore. And what I worked
on next was motivated by the fact that it
seemed that random walks in graphs, and expanded
graphs, and properties of expanders and so
on, seemed to also come up a lot in various
areas of complexity theory.
So I thought I would spend maybe a few months learning about spectral graph theory from the beginning,
and have those techniques a bit more clear
in my mind. Well, that was five years ago,
and I'm still working on it, because I found
that it was so much... there are so many open questions
and it's so connected to new work
on approximation algorithms, or even exact
algorithms - like the work on max flow using
electrical networks.
Yes, that's right. And so much that you are
going to be having this semester program starting
in a few days.
Yes. Next week, or in a couple of weeks, we'll
be having the program on spectral graph theory,
where all the people who we were hoping would
come came. And it promises to be really exciting.
It's coming at the right time: There are already
a lot of things that people have been developing,
and it's a good place to share them. But it
also seems that there is a tipping point,
and something much bigger is going to happen.
And maybe the Institute...
We want to be the locus, the place for tipping
points. That's what the Simons Institute,
as you know, is for. Yes, right... How are
you looking at your role at the Institute?
You know, when I interviewed here at Berkeley,
it was a bit different from the way interviews
usually go. Because there everybody tells
you what the place is like, and what your
work is going to be like in this place. But
when I interviewed here, people were asking me...
You define it.
"What are you going to do with this Senior
Scientist job?" And I'm still not so sure.
But I think that really, ever since that experience at MIT
Let me tell you: Two years later, I have no
idea. (Laughs.)
Ever since that experience at MIT, with that
reading group, where we were just interested
in one thing and all kinds of things came
out of it, I've really been interested in
exploring new things I don't know much about.
Serendipity. Yes. I love that. This sounds
like a great plan.
It seems here, I can do that as a job.
As a job, and very intensely. Yes, right.
When new things are coming up, and try to
connect with people who might be good organizers
for new programs...